[Music]
ransomware
is everywhere um it's it's happening to
the
the biggest companies the cyber weapon
not petya started in ukraine
in june of 2017. it quickly spread
paralyzing major companies
and causing more than 10 billion dollars
in damage government computers in 22
texas towns are being held
hostage by ransomware but it's also
happening at you know
super low levels and you know where you
have people
uh ransoming individuals for for small
amounts of money
and the thing that was the thing that
was most interesting and the thing that
like sort of set us down this path
is this thing called ransomware as a
service and as soon as you hear that
phrase you're you know i mean i want to
read about that the idea that
um that people could buy ransomware the
same way they buy
um salesforce software or or anything
else
and so then we decided to uh
send drake you know onto the dark web to
to procure some ransomware service
with a story like this all the reasons
not to do it are actually the reasons to
do it
[Music]
my name is drake bennett i went on the
dark web i bought some malware
and i used it to attack and extort my
editor max chavkin
the original idea was just to do
something
about ransomware um the city of
baltimore you know was having this like
huge
sort of battle with with some hackers
thousands of
baltimore city computers frozen by
hackers demanding ransom
baltimore's government computer systems
recently faced a ransomware attack
are you seeing these attacks become more
sophisticated the more i
learned about this world the more uh
frustrated i got it seems
hard to know what you can trust here
there's a lot of anonymity
the more i thought about it the more it
seemed like it might make sense to
try it myself he wanted to to do
something participatory
it's um it's really a cool way to kind
of
explain a really difficult technical
topic
and then that also has the added benefit
of testing out a hypothesis i've begun
to have which is that
this stuff has gotten so easy for a
variety of reasons that almost anyone
could launch one of these attacks
and as it happens i'd be a particularly
good guinea pig for this because i'm
particularly technologically
illiterate
you know you got to have a hacker and
that that hacker
you know despite his um i'd say modest
um
uh computing skills is drake and the
victim
uh was me and our idea was that drake
could
you know he's sending the attachments
all the time so the way we decided he
was going to do it is he was going to
you know pretend to send me a draft but
that but that draft was going to be
ransomware
what were some of the legal concerns and
how did you get around those
okay um legal concerns what we figured
out in
in consultation with um a very uh
amused and maybe slightly confused uh
bloomberg
lawyer was that all of the laws that are
on the books require
not only the possession of malware but
the intent to actually launch an attack
against an unwitting victim max my
victim
was complicit in the scheme so we
figured that
kept us on the right side of the law and
i do think there's like a really
strong um public interest argument for
doing this kind of thing
because if somebody as like as
unsophisticated
as like a magazine journalist can can
get
you know really dangerous ransomware
without spending very much money
that's something that i think the public
needs to know about
so once we kind of you know talked to
bloomberg lawyer we then got two
burner laptops we got two cheap dell
laptops
max and i both work for a company that
uh takes data security very seriously
uh for obvious reasons uh so we
made sure that we kept all this off uh
bloomberg's network
then we decided to uh send him uh you
know onto the dark web to
to procure some ransomware service so
there are these
dark web forums that work sort of like
they're chat rooms but they're also
these
kind of malware bazaars where you can go
and people are hawking different
different forms of malware and
also different ways of getting that
malware onto
computer systems the market has now kind
of advanced to the point where
there are these services they're called
ransomware as a service and it's a play
on this idea of software as a service
or sas which is something you hear in
silicon valley all the time
and so i found a couple um you know some
of them turned out to be bogus some of
them
seemed to be defunct people just didn't
get back to me but there was one
where the guy got back to me when i got
in touch with them and
answered the few questions i had and it
was cheap
you know it's just 150 bucks so i
figured it was worth a try
so the first thing i did is i reached
out to the vendor
and i used protonmail which is a which
is an encrypted email service
and at that point i had gone ahead and
set up a bitcoin
wallet so i paid the 150
that was the subscription fee for the
service
and that gave me a login for this
website
and it was a pretty simple looking
interface there was
there was a series of tabs at the top of
the screen
one of the tabs um took me to the quote
unquote dashboard which
is where i'd be able to manage the
various attacks um
there was another tab that uh that took
me to what was called the builder
which is a page that allowed me to input
a few pieces of information about the
kind of malware i wanted
stuff like what kind of operating system
would be on the target computer
or what kind of encryption i wanted or
what's the email address that my victims
should use to contact me
once they realize they've been attacked
so i input those few
pieces of information and it spits out
um
a piece of software that i could then
download onto my computer
so it became obvious pretty quickly that
i didn't have particularly top shelf
product um and you know that's not
surprising you know
a lot of the conversation on these dark
web forums is about whether this or that
product is
reliable or how well it works the the
person that we bought the ransomware
from turned out to be not the most
sophisticated you know almost as
unsophisticated as we were and it and it
kind of started to become unclear
whether
he was trying to to con us out of more
money and
i kept saying him you know we got to be
really careful that there's not
like an additional layer to this scam
that he's not going to ask us to wire
him some more money to make
to make the uh to make the software work
better and which is what he was trying
to do
so there's just like so much kind of con
artistry
and there does seem to be a wide range
in
quality you know reflected partly in the
wide range of price
i mean there are other ones that are
much more high-end where
it's not even a it's not even kind of an
annual
fee model it's more like you have a gang
of hackers
with different sort of specialties and
they just divide up the pot between them
so i wrote my email to max which
basically said hey max
here's the draft of my latest story
sorry it's taken so long
the draft is attached even though i had
a really bad laptop
it immediately was sniffed out
the the you know the potential that this
that this attachment that drake was
sending me which looked super suspicious
to me
uh going to do was going to do harm and
there were a bunch of warning boxes that
opened up
saying you know are you really sure you
want to you know load up this file are
you
are you super sure and um and of course
i said yes yes and
and and infected myself and then max
kind of looked away for a second and
looked back at his computer and there
was this
ghoulish image of like a you know hand
reaching out from a cloud of smoke
and a message that said all of your
files have now been encrypted
um and so i was sitting there um you
know
waiting for this thing to happen we had
a photographer there all of the
documents you know i had to load the
laptop with a bunch of documents that
that i wasn't afraid to lose so like i
didn't have anything
important on there and there's still
something really scary
about you know seeing that message on
your computer
um that you know says that they
own you now that the that the attacker
has your files
and is gonna do you know is going to do
with you what he wants
and and it really makes you realize you
know how how easy it is
you know to become a victim
the the communities of people who are in
this world
range from you know kind of like the
most sophisticated hacker so like
state supported you know connected to
um the military or intelligence
operation
of some of the most powerful countries
in the world all the way down
to like a board you know literally like
a board teenager
after all this was over i did reach out
to my
ransomware providers you know and
announced myself as a journalist and
you know they uh consented to be
interviewed
and basically what they told me they
didn't say much about themselves but
they did say that they were
a group of 18 to 26 year olds uh with
different
kind of you know specializations um
working as a team to create this stuff
a lot of the a lot of these chat rooms
where these uh products are bought and
sold
are russian language chat rooms uh some
of them actually been
geofenced or coded in such a way that
they only
that they'll work anywhere except in
places like russia
ukraine so but i don't know where
particularly
my uh providers were located
i also think you know it was surprising
in a good way
that um that we really had to work to
make this work in terms of
in terms of me ignoring warnings that my
computer was giving
in terms of drake um having to work with
an expert
to to to get the ransomware to work uh
perfectly
but it's just a it's just kind of like a
scary reminder of
um how all of this kind of um
they're all these sort of bad actors and
and
and creeps and con artists um kind of
lingering just just below the surface of
the internet
and um and and it's kind of creepy how
close they are and and how
how how you know you're you're not that
far away
from downloading something um that can
kind of mess up your digital life
you